[Music]
I ever missing the show
so every industry has a heart
hardworking person well they said this
guy's the hardest-working guy in this
industry in sports and business in any
world I am sitting next to a guy that
for those of you if you follow India and
you know exactly who it is especially
with the fact that he's wearing is a
conservative three-piece suit mr. Steve
Aoki and if you don't know him let me
give you some stats for some of you that
maybe don't listen to EDM and maybe
you're hiding under a cave his peers
like Tiesto calls them that you know
he's a whole different guy from a
different planet there's not even a guy
like him in the world
Afrojack says he changed the game they
call him a beast the guy's the
hardest-working guy in business Guinness
Book of World Record contacts them to
say no one works harder than he's the
hardest-working musician in the world
Forbes ranked him top five highest paid
DJ's I think twenty nine and a half
million dollars in 2017 that's what we
sit in with today so with that being
said Steve brother thank you listen
we're taking the time man this is really
cool to sit in and talk to you
especially after watching your
documentary thank you I got a two story
about how I watch a documentary so we
just moved into a new house okay and I
obviously I know your music but we moved
into this new house the the team says
Pat you gotta watch his documentary your
documentary guy you'll flip I want to
watch his documentary I said okay I'll
get to it so I get on the Netflix phone
and it's 12 o'clock last night I'm
sitting in the bathroom which is where
we watch most of it and I'm sitting
there with my dog to my lip all the kids
everybody asleep I'm watching this thing
and I'm like I'm getting emotional I got
tears coming out and I'm getting fired
up and I'm getting jacked up and then I
comments your mom makes your dad I mean
that's gotta be one of the best
documentaries out there with your life
thank you so with that being said prior
to us getting into some of the business
stuff what you've done where you're at
family your father rocky your mom how
did this whole thing start like did you
start off day one obviously I know this
story but for some that don't did you
all over someone they say I want to be a
DJ how did that come about yeah you know
my story's a little different because I
think a lot of kids in the festival's
games they're in the crowd there 14 15
and they like they see it on YouTube and
like I want to be a DJ I want to be on
that stage
but my my world came very differently I
I came from the rock world and I was
playing in rooms this size you know when
I first started I was in high school and
I would play to as many people that's in
this room literally I was literally
played at like five people and their
parents five kids they're all my friends
and that's really how it all started for
me like I it's all for me the most
important thing I learned is that the
barrier of entry to get in was
conceivable because like when you're a
kid in the crowd you look at this stage
you're like the barrier of entry for me
to become an artist is impossible like
it never be as talented yeah I can never
I could never have the courage or I can
never have the voice or didn't think
that were you thinking not like while
you're looking at everybody oh yeah yeah
I mean I think I think everyone does
I think everyone's like the barrier of
entry is way too difficult i I know how
the training I don't I don't not like
trained or I don't have the schools that
I found this really vibrant underground
scene of musicians and artists this is
in Newport is in Newport Beach it was a
the the scene itself was it's called the
hardcore scene and it's a very
specifically the straightedge hardcore
scene which is a like really a drug
drug-free about drug free lifestyle and
you just go to shows the way you get
cool points in the scene is not like
with like like dope sneakers in like a
dope track suit that you're wearing but
it's like make a zine just put on a show
start a band become a guitarist you know
and you're becoming like because it
seems so small it's like I'll religion
it's like we are this small church and
we need to expand our you know our base
by giving out like flyers and all of you
at this time like when you're going I
was like 15 16 no so that's what I ended
up doing I was making scenes I picked up
guitar I picked up a microphone I picked
up way to record music I started a band
with like my friends that didn't know
how to play we'd set up everywhere we
would set up in like in like a plaza and
until it cops came and we just grabbed
our drum set and run away like literally
would set up everywhere would play
everywhere and if five people came out
we were super excited and then I got to
the point when I went to college where
we I started touring and we went from
five
playing for 20 people and it was so
happy and 20 people yeah like you know
like as 1920 I was like alright we're
gonna drive ten hours to Albuquerque and
we made $20 at the door and we may play
in front of 12 people and it's amazing
that you're doing that it was my heart
it was my passion it wasn't about money
it wasn't about you know I mean I was a
kid I just really believed in music now
who were you in high school were you
were you were you a cool cat on high
school did everybody know who Steve was
in high school no I mean I know I mean I
definitely stood out because I was only
like one of the few Asian people in the
school you know when I was younger I was
bullied and those you know the whole
story I'm I could really get into that
but one of the most important things
that I recognize now is that when I was
a kid when you're when you're like one
of the few that look different or are
different or ethnically different or
whatever it might be you might think
that life is help right you might think
that like and some some kids
unfortunately take their own lives
because they they feel so pushed out to
the side and where people say the
horrible most horrible things you could
possibly imagine
so when you're an Asian kid if you're a
like a kid of color you're someone is
different and you get made fun of it's
it's like almost okay and to be accepted
as that so for me I grew up under this
guise of well I I'm not equal to you
know my peers you would think that yeah
because I mean like it just was that's
how it was so my mom was like we have to
fit in here we have to fit in so don't
cause any trouble don't rock the boat
the thing is like you always find the
gem in the rough some places and I was
able to find this scene that was like a
bunch of like outcasts every song every
lyric from the bands that listened to
was about like this is like we're the
outcasts we're the we are the people
that don't fit in hey this is our world
this or did you listen to who were you
listening to at that time Gorilla
Biscuits which is like I get my first
tattoo I was like so excited when I was
18 I was like my first tattoo young girl
this kids in the band that kind of was
one of the leaders of that see it sound
and it's like a way for us to feel like
hey we are something like no one can no
one can tear us down here's
the instrument be a voice for yourself
be a voice for your community and and I
just took that same the same kind of
process into every business into every
brand building into my music the
underdog mentality type of thing or more
of this kind of like DIY mentality where
it's DIY in my way of understanding it
is you you must you have to figure out
how to make ends meet
with the resources in front of you so
there's no excuses if you have if you
have a dollar to your name you got to
learn how to use that dollar to to
actually become a star as they've always
been a hustler like that like even when
you were a little kid or did that hustle
part come later on the hustle part know
the hustles part started because I found
a scene that encouraged that it was all
about that dog you want it you want to
get your respect then you got to figure
it out I graduated from college and I
moved to Los Angeles and I was throwing
parties and I've had my label I started
a label when I was in college and no
investment no marketing plan no
investors you know very much like like a
passion project to support artists and I
found a few artists that blew up and and
you know like no advance no money and by
the way your first place your first
office it is very interesting so that's
the actual first headquarters a year
your operation yeah my first
headquarters was a I'm not sure what was
in the dock but my first real
headquarters was an apartment that's 900
square feet I share with my girlfriend
of the time and we had 13 interns
working for me because they were
freaking us I didn't have any money not
underscore food plays yeah I mean it was
tiny and then finally I got my first
investors which were Benji and Joel from
Good Charlotte who I taught them how to
DJ back then I was hang out with them
they were like my closest resident and
they were in a successful band and
they're like diehard believers of you by
the way yeah they're just a really
really good people they're like let me
see what you're doing you're you know
how to sign you know how to find
identify talent and we really love the
culture and community that you're
creating and we want to help you so they
helped take me out of my apartment and
put
into this like almost abandoned like
little house and I just threw all my
friends in there some of us lived there
and and we had this like this such a
really cool small little community in
Hollywood that eventually became
literally the place where you want to
break artists it was at the DMACC
parties there like amazing from Kid Cudi
like Drake was coming through to Kanye
was coming through - Skrillex was that
way and will.i.am will.i.am was there
every show and then I got to meet all
these artists because we were breaking
you know we had mi a s first show all
these new artists who were coming up
Kesha's first shows like from pop to
hip-hop to electronic it was the culture
of breaking music the bigwigs would come
through a Jimmy Iovine showed up like
like you know I was meeting up with
labels they would come to me to break
their artists and then you know some of
the guys were like I'll take a risk with
you and do music with you and I was like
let's get in a studio and so I was lucky
I had that platform that we had to build
our own little culture that just spawned
into you know something that was there
was actually have truly underground
because back then there was no social
media I mean the social media was like
MySpace so there's no snapchat what year
is this by the way
it's like 2005 to 2009 and and if you
want to hear about the underground if
you want to know about the underground
the only way you have to go into these
clubs these small little places now it's
not so you don't have to really go there
it's everywhere it's just like you want
to know about something that's breaking
you go online and and before you'd have
to go and like people would travel
around the world just to come to our
little parties where where you'd see
like all these different collaborations
lancers and people that would all really
value the time there and and then I
would I would be able to work with some
of these artists and they're thinking
about money were you at all thinking
about what we're gonna build a business
we're gonna build was that it was out on
your mind as always they're just purely
art creativity you know let's produce
something nice here together you know
what even to this day 2018 it's always
been about creativity it's never been
about money I mean at the end of the day
of course I am thinking business now
because I'm at a larger scale and I have
to think about the business but if I put
the money before the creativity then the
authenticity like almost gets blocked
you know so I have to really because my
business is all about authentically
being creative that's my business it's
like I just I want to be authentically
creative and share that experience
because at the end of the day whatever I
do is about I am I am making creations
whether its product fashion this is not
mine but like fashion to music to a live
experience I'm creating something that
that I'm sharing with you now if I'm
like I need money first before you even
see this you know if I start thinking
like that then I'm gonna lose that that
kind of disappears
yeah the day you know like it's you know
money will come and I've realized that
and is in its in some cases money
doesn't come and now I'm okay with that
and I have to go back to that go like
this isn't about money this is about the
love of what I do and sometimes you have
to stop and think about that and and as
a businessman you know you have to like
take a step back like this isn't about
dollars and cents this is more about
just just the pure love of creating and
and sharing your art let's transition to
a whole different topic here one of the
things that I'm fascinated with the
stories like parents I look at my own
family I grew up in a very weird family
complete like one on this side one on
the complete my mother sided with
communist my dad said they were
imperialists in Iran confusion like I
grew up in the most craziest environment
did you tell your story and I'm sinners
saying oh my gosh so your mom on one end
purely love you know she believed in you
totally you can do this go get them do
what you want to do you can do this you
can pull this off you can see this woman
your mother loves you believes in you
you can do anything wrong by your mom
and then your dad on the complete
opposite end you know where it was high
expectation you know a possible shadow
how was that dynamic with your
yeah yeah well you see it like that it's
true look like without both of them
there's no like I am the byproduct of
these two very different personalities
and thank God that that my mom raised me
because I think the most important thing
is you have to be founded with that love
you have to be founded with that human
connection and my dad lacked the human
connection it was very very very like
almost I wouldn't say cold but he was
very Japanese very masculine very tough
love and you never asked for a thing
from him you would never dare very
samurai spirit I never asked anything
from oh you oh you could it I mean one
of the most important lessons I learned
from him someone that that had wealth
had the opportunity had everything that
he built the one of the most important
things I got from him is that he
actually didn't give me any financial
you know like here's her payday here
like you need some help here some money
so he never actually like gave me those
handouts and I had to learn on my own
like as if I didn't have just insane
like a superhero kind of Rockstar
extravagant because that's common you
know a lot of time when the dad has the
money it kind of gets you know yeah yeah
of course
Daniel I guess the part of your story
that I think it's people resonate about
this guy didn't he comes from money but
he didn't get you didn't get money to
finance your own company when you first
guys not but I mean I I do have to say
he helped me he paid for half of my
education in college so I give him
credit for that my mom paid for the
other half UCSB the UC system awesome
education for very I mean it was only
thirteen thousand a year you know this
is where this is a 90 right there's 95
to 2000 so as far as I'm a fat check
that but I think it was like less than
15 grand a year this is real education
yeah yeah so he covered the education my
mom bought me my car Isuzu Rodeo that I
like drove the ground so something about
your debt something like the some of the
things I heard him say by the way
believe me I relate a lot of the life is
I'm reading them I'm watching I relate
to this apart we I think your dad
at one time first of all for some people
that don't know where your dad is the
founder of Benihana
he was a champion wrestler I think he
was doing speedboating a couple times he
almost killed myself it was a story
about him and in hot-air-balloon going
from Japan to us or whatever broke a
world record you know all these are the
things that he did he party with he's
been on Oprah Winfrey Show you know he
was on all these Tony Curtis I think it
was all these other names so you're
Muhammad Ali all these names he'd said
something one time and I'm like you know
I'm really curious how do you process on
when you watch him say that I think one
time he said I work 16 17 hours a day
Venus comes number one
and health number two and family comes
number three is that what he meant
or did he say because me you know
sometimes media takes imagine somebody's
and they kind of spin it yeah is that
what he said or does that really what he
believed he lived that way he was he was
like he wasn't a typical father you know
that was there like you know making sure
like my mom was my father and my mother
likes far as the what you expectation
what a parent is he wasn't that so
that's what I'm saying think I my mom
raised me because I'd be a different
person if I was with my dad but yeah he
was business first and to be like the
biggest it's like when I see that when I
saw that it is all it further for the
first time in the documentary I started
laughing so you haven't seen him say
that before no no I never I never saw
the interview you know so I I and my
first reaction I was laughing because he
was just unabashed in a way where you
just like you almost have to laugh it's
like so gnarly and you have to laugh
about it you know so I was laughing I'm
now I'm looking at other people I'm
because I watched it for the first time
in beacon theatres with like 3,000 other
people and for the Tribeca Film Festival
and I looked over and people like home
like God like that's horrible I'm like
I'm laughing I'm like only one laughing
you know I'm like oh yeah this is like I
shouldn't be laughing but that's just
how he is
so it was normally like I don't want to
go surprised this is the normal guy used
to that's how easy is just like what
those guys that just says it how he
thinks it so there's a part of the
interview
we're part of the documentary where you
are you're driving your team you're
telling your manager you know this is
your job you're doing this so you know
sometimes you we see the final product
right we see that we see the art we see
art we see the music we see the
entertain more like oh my gosh this
guy's amazing throwing cakes you know
fifteen hundred cakes around and all the
stuff that you're doing put them behind
the final product you tour in 250 you
st. 250 tour stops per year that's that
leaves you a hundred days to yourself is
there a part of it on behind closed
doors of driving your team in a way
where your expectation of the team is
high and extremely high so how do you
balance that with the fun and staying
loose on at the same time hey we got to
go out there and do our German doing it
right there's a part of it that's
perfection aside right the fun part is a
very small part of the day it's actually
just 90 minutes to two hours that's it
the other hours we're going to work and
the team has to operate at that level so
I have a high expectation and I'll
almost get that definitely at that for
my father there's no doubt like that
that side for my father has come down
and I and I had that high expectation
and once my team meets that high
expectation then I'm then I'm like I
feel solid because you know what like I
think a common phrase for a lot of CEOs
a lot of entrepreneurs out there is that
your team you have to be the dumbest
person in the room if you have if you're
gonna have a successful company you know
if you're the CEO you want to be not the
smartest person in the room you want
your team to be the sharpest sword in
the game so another thing also I learned
is that as far as building a team I look
at passion before skillset like you have
to have a level of skill set of course
just just enough where you know you can
grow and nurture that but you have to
have the passion you have to have to
drive to learn and be hungry and and I
also learned that hunger doesn't also
just come with with the youth I'm 40
years old now and I'm [ __ ] hungry as
I've ever been seriously I still let's
tell me why because like others I look
at like all the the things that I still
need to do and there's still so much
more so as if I'm starting from one so
that hunger is still there that
Firestone the belly and the more I
travel the more I learn
that I I know very little about the
world and I and I become you know hungry
to be become that student and and
embrace and absorb culture and absorb
and learn that I need to educate on all
these things and it's all gonna it's all
gonna reverberate into my business
whatever my business might be because
the way the way I am as a person
I think this is also part of my
successes that the minute I feel
something that's that's like really
powerful inspirational to me mm-hmm the
minute I feel that way I'm immediately
going into my head and how can I
construct this in a way to share it with
the world and I share I share that
feeling in different mediums through
music through fashion through the live
experience through different products
through whatever it might be that all
come from this abundant amount of
inspiration and I can only get that by
being around people connecting with
people seeing different things that just
like enlightened me and and then like I
said it goes right back to see ya me
going I need I still got so much more to
go
you know and it drives me it drives me
and it keeps me hungry so so that's the
part where you're always in recreation
what you're always recreating yourself
constantly in the recreation mode well
Steve you you got to be one of the most
fascinating people I've met with men I
mean seriously you're just very
interesting on a creative end and also
on the execution end and you can see it
here right now with the team that you
put together brother thank you so much
for taking the time to meet with us
definitely thank you